[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
My name is Daniel Pham
and welcome to "This Week
in Android Development" on
Monday, November 25, 2013.
All of our Retos
seem to be missing,
so I'm back again
this week to share
what's been going
on around here.
Last week, "Game On!"
returned from hiatus
to celebrate the half
birthday of "Play Games."
In app update news,
"HBO Go" has been
updated to include both
support for the latest wafery,
chocolatey version
of Android, as well
as Chromecast integration.
While ESPN Sports Center has
been revamped with a fresh new
look.
The app looks great, but
upon closer inspection,
it looks like they're
showing the wrong score
from last season's Superbowl.
We all know the
Ravens were shut out,
and the Niners put up a
thousand unanswered points--
just like they're going to
do today to the Redskins.
This week, be sure to
check out another episode
of "Android Design in Action."
The gang will be sharing
their favorite design details
in an exciting new format.
For those of you in
the US, hope you're
ready to eat way too
much this Thursday.
So Happy Thanksgiving,
and safe travels.
That's all for this week
in "Android Development."
Be sure to check out
this week's shows.
I'm Daniel Pham.
And remember-- "It
means no worries
for the rest of your days.
It's our problem free
philosophy-- Hakuna Matata."